do you have any idea how insulting that
is
i make my own decisions for my own
reasons you got to listen to me the man
needs help howard
i know jimmy and you're wrong
hey guys pete here can you believe it's
been two years since the better call
saul season five finale no one can blame
you for being a little fuzzy on the
details at this point and i'm making
this video after re-watching the entire
series just in case you didn't have time
to do the same since this is a prequel
and a sequel we know how things end for
a lot of the main characters but
considering there's still about four
years between the last episode of better
call saul and the first episode of
breaking bad there are still a lot of
fascinating questions left to answer of
course the biggest questions relate to
the characters we don't see during the
original series kim nacho and lalo other
questions that tend to get thrown around
a lot are when will jimmy fully become
saul and after season 5 are we going to
see kim break bad are we gonna see slip
and kimmy i tend to think that both of
these things already happened honestly i
think the two finger gun moments were
the exclamation points on those
sentences jimmy officially started
practicing as saul goodman after being
reinstated and his strategy of leaning
into being the kind of lawyer guilty
people hire is there he isn't yet the
same person it's a bit like a snowball
rolling downhill what happens next will
shape him they'll lead him to honing
that persona to becoming that person we
first met but the main difference right
now is that kim is still the most
important thing in jimmy's life while
saul only appeared to care about money
and then maybe the thrill of what he's
able to get away with saying that kim
has already broken bad might be an
oversimplification but she has made the
decision to go after howard for what she
thinks is a good reason this is new
territory for her and this move might
come with consequences none of us are
ready for and i will come back to both
jimmy and kim to refresh you on where
they're at at the beginning of season 6.
during the breaking bad series saul
goodman is the guy you go to in
albuquerque when you need a criminal
lawyer emphasis on criminal someone who
isn't above playing fast and loose with
the rules this reputation led to him
becoming the personal lawyer of the
infamous meth cook walter white and that
relationship led to him having to flee
and go into hiding at the end of that
series better call saul opens in omaha
nebraska where you see that this
throwaway line to walter white about
becoming a manager at a cinnabon turned
out to come true the new series starts
out there but it doesn't linger you get
exactly one scene in omaha at the
beginning of each season where you see
that saul has taken on the fake identity
gene takabic he's set up in a normal if
not boring life but it's clear that he
lives in constant fear of his true
identity being exposed that eventually
happens in the season 5 gene scene when
he's approached by a taxi driver from
albuquerque and he calls ed to disappear
with the intention of running again
during their call he changes his mind
and his story is left with him saying
that he'll handle it himself what
happens to gene aka saul aka jimmy is
arguably the biggest question there is
his ending is the end of the story
probably the very last thing that we'll
see in this universe people used to
question about what kind of charges he
might be facing what was he really on
the run from or even if the authorities
would still be looking for him after
five tenth seasons i don't think there's
any question that his paranoia is well
warranted he's not in a bubble he knows
what's going on in the outside world and
his identity being exposed is a huge
deal you see that he had the ability to
run it felt like that was probably the
safest option but he chose to go this
different route to take action maybe go
into saw mode one last time the series
opened with gene and it will likely end
there and i'm hoping we'll get to spend
a fair amount of time seeing how that
plays out
nacho varga is another character whose
end is in question and is also on the
run at the end of season 5. nacho
started out as a pretty straightforward
criminal type who worked for the
salamanca family you do end up rooting
for him by the end of the series but it
wasn't always that way over time he
wants to get out of the life but each
attempt he makes to try to get out
backfires on him leaving him more
entrenched and generally worse off a lot
of why he becomes so sympathetic is
because his father who's a civilian gets
caught up in things and he tries to make
that right initially hector wanted to
take over his upholstery business and
wanted to use it as a front for their
smuggling so that he wouldn't have to
rely on gus that led nacho to try to
kill hector by swapping out his heart
medication with dummy capsules filled
with ibuprofen after the attempt was
unsuccessful gus figured out what he
tried to do and he realized that he
could use that information to force him
to become a mole in the salamanca
organization nacho knows that if he
doesn't do what he's told his father
will pay the ultimate price and he
hasn't been able to convince him that
their only option is to run by the end
of season 5 lalo has introduced him to
don elattio as the salamanca's guy in
the north for at least the 10 remaining
months until tuko gets out of prison
while he's in mexico gus uses him to
open up lalo's compound for the
mercenaries he's hired to kill him he
does get away but lolo now knows he was
involved which is a big problem since
he's not dead his story will pick up in
season six with him trying to get out of
the country where he doesn't really have
anyone he can trust the salamancas and
the cartel will be after him and he's a
liability to gus because he could
implicate him under questioning mike has
tried to talk gus into letting him get
out but so far that's fallen on deaf
ears he may be nacho's only hope in a
situation where it's in gus's interest
to get him away from the salamancas but
where it would also make sense to
eliminate him once he's back in the u.s
what happens to lalo is also a big
question nacho and lalo are characters
that were created from a throwaway line
from jimmy when walt and jesse were
trying to scare him into becoming
badger's lawyer when they took him out
into the desert he says it wasn't me it
was ignacio referring to nacho and then
he's relieved when he finds out that it
wasn't lalo that sent them that would
indicate that saul thinks lalo is still
alive or at the very least he doesn't
know what happened to him that
contradicts gus telling hector that
everyone in his family is dead and that
the salamanca name ends with him later
in the series for what it's worth gus
seems like a more reliable source lalo
entered the story towards the end of
season 4 and has injected some life into
the cartel side of things he quickly
became a worthy adversary for gus
causing him a lot of problems his place
in the salamanca family his connection
to the cartel made him untouchable
especially north of the border where gus
would be the prime suspect if anything
happened to him this led to the plan to
have him arrested for the money wire
killing that involved an innocent
citizen then gus used jimmy to get him
out of jail so that he would be forced
to jump bail and flee back to mexico
from there gus made his move at the end
of season 5 he sent that group of
mercenaries to take him out and they
failed so lalo knows that gus was behind
that it should be clear that nacho was
involved but he also has the problem
that he's wanted in the united states of
course it's under a different name but
it probably won't be long before they
realized that that was fake this could
mean that he might reach out to jimmy
who is now a friend of the cartel and
what a journey he's had to get to that
point when we first met jimmy mcgill the
man that we'll eventually know as saul
goodman he was working as a public
defender out of the back of a nail salon
driving around in a suzuki esteem there
was very little of the soul we knew from
breaking bad in this character in the
beginning he was far from successful but
he did take the idea of being a lawyer
seriously he has a checkered past he was
a low-level scammer known as slipping
jimmy back in cicero illinois he gets
himself in some trouble but he also has
a knack for being able to talk his way
out of difficult situations his antics
and a chicago sunroof in particular got
him in a situation where he was in real
trouble with the law he was about to go
to prison he had to reach out for the
help of his brother chuck who was a
well-respected lawyer to get him out of
the situation and part of that was him
straightening up his life and moving to
albuquerque to take a job in the
mailroom of one of the most respected
law firms in the city that's also where
he meets his girlfriend kim wexler
in the early going jimmy is mostly
trying to turn his life around he does
still have that tendency to cut corners
but he works hard and he's dedicated to
taking care of his brother who believes
he has a condition that makes him
allergic to electricity
he does his best to leave the life of
slipping jimmy behind he gets his law
degree and is hoping to get hired on at
hhm just like kim did but is led to
believe that howard hamlin doesn't want
him there the big reveal at the end of
season one after he pulls his stunt with
the kettleman's to show that he can do
the right thing he learns that it's been
his brother chuck that's been holding
him back the whole time chuck doesn't
believe he can change he doesn't believe
he's a real lawyer and in his words
jimmy with a law degree is like a chimp
with a machine gun the two brothers go
to war and eventually jimmy loses his
license to practice for a year chuck was
trying to get him permanently disbarred
though and in their final battle jimmy
had to team up with kim to keep that
from happening they set up chuck to
humiliate himself in public in court in
front of his peers and he never really
recovered from that he started to turn
things around for a period and jimmy did
come around and try to mend their
relationship only to be rejected by his
brother one last time in the end jimmy
tipped off the insurance company about
chuck's outburst in court they
threatened to raise the malpractice
rates for the entire firm so howard
asked chuck to consider retirement he
fought back that led to howard forcing
him out and his condition came back
bringing him so low that he decided to
take his own life jimmy knows that the
stunt with the insurance company set off
the chain of events that led to chuck's
suicide he spent most of season 4 unable
to deal with what happened he was never
able to process the loss of his brother
he also wasn't able to practice law so
he spent most of his time selling drop
phones to criminals and that turned out
to be a successful hustle he got the
idea to practice law with the same name
that he was using with this clientele
since they were all the kind of people
that would eventually need a lawyer he
officially became saul goodman he
primarily focused on these kinds of
clients and the days of him trying to be
a respectable lawyer to make his brother
proud have all but slipped away
he'll throw himself into this new
practice and things will conspire so
that he won't have much time to reflect
on how losing his brother is affecting
his life in the first half of season 5
kim continues to focus on doing pro bono
work this serves as a way for her to get
back and she finds it more interesting
and rewarding than the banking law she
does for mesa verde she's called in to
deal with a property owner who refuses
to leave his home even though mesa verde
is legally entitled to it mr acker has a
way of getting under her skin he lumps
her in with the rich people she works
for he hits a nerve and makes her
question her motives and that leads to
her enlisting jimmy to represent him to
go against her own firm she works hard
to give mesa birdie an out one that
would see mr acker stay in his house but
her client kevin wachtel won't back down
jimmy eventually encourages her to let
it go but she decides that she wants to
take things to the next level they plan
to go after kevin personally and force
him to back down she eventually changes
her mind though when she realizes that
it's causing problems at her firm and
she tells jimmy to call off the plan he
sees an opportunity to pull it off
without her and at the same time make it
look like he was doing this all on his
own from the beginning because they are
a couple there was suspicion that they
were working together in his mind this
would actually be good for kim and we
see that she is visibly enraged by his
actions in the meeting so it is
successful in that sense but this also
crosses a line for her he made her the
sucker and she doesn't see any way
forward for them other than to break up
or maybe they should just get married
and that's what they decide to do now
this does establish spousal privilege
but they also have genuine feelings for
each other which come up when they
exchange their vows and throughout the
rest of the season part of this new
arrangement is that jimmy has to tell
her things that he might not want to she
wants to know what he's up to what's
going on with him and we had seen that
they drifted apart that they were sort
of living separate lives towards the end
of the third season and into the fourth
as i've already touched on jimmy does
get involved with lalo and becomes a
friend of the cartel this will bring up
the first test of him being honest with
her he tells her the truth about going
to pick up lalo's bail from the cousins
near the border she thinks it's way too
dangerous she's not okay with it and
more she doesn't understand why this is
so important to him he tells her she's
worried about nothing he goes through
with it anyways and of course things go
wrong he does pick up the money but he's
ambushed by a gang of armed criminals
who are there to take it away from him
and he would have died right there if it
weren't for mike intervening and saving
the day this leads to a brutal trek
through the desert after the esteem
finally craps out jimmy has to carry the
bag spilled with lalo's 7 million
dollars in cash and almost doesn't make
it kim is completely cut off from jimmy
and terrified she even goes to visit
lalo in jail to see if she can learn
anything and then she just sort of has
to sit and wait nervously in their
apartment until jimmy finally gets a
sell signal he goes to pay the bail and
lola is released and then he does come
home in the aftermath this bad decision
only seems to pull them closer together
jimmy is wrecked physically and he's
suffering from ptsd and kim just takes
care of him overlooking the fact that
she knows he hasn't told her the whole
story things get intense when lalo
decides to go investigate things on his
way back to mexico he finds jimmy's car
it has bullet holes in it so he comes
back to their apartment for answers
jimmy sticks to his story because mike
told him that he had to and lalo
continues to press him until kim steps
up to take control of the conversation
she defends jimmy and turns things back
on lolo until he eventually leaves the
apartment to head back to mexico with
nacho jimmy does come clean about what
really happened in the desert and they
decide to go and stay in a hotel because
they think that might be safer than
staying in their apartment kim has
already quit her job at schweikert and
coakley so she heads to the courthouse
and picks up 20 new pro bono cases jimmy
is a basket case he's worried about lalo
and so he goes to talk to mike to find
out why he couldn't tell him the truth
about what happened mike lets him know
that there's a plan in motion where lalo
will be killed once he gets back to
mexico and that's all he can tell him so
way back in the beginning when jimmy was
doing elder law he discovered that
sandpiper crossing was overcharging its
residents and defrauding them out of
their money this led to a massive class
action suit by hhm and davis in maine
which will eventually provide jimmy with
a seven-figure payday this is something
that takes a long time though and at the
end of season 5 kim comes up with this
plan to try to force the settlement
early so that she can open up an office
and have a completely pro bono practice
this will require doing something
terrible to howard something that would
generate enough negative attention that
it would make more sense for the firms
to take sam piper's offer and settle
just to make the story go away jimmy
thinks this is going too far and
initially tries to talk her out of it
they have a history with howard and he's
certainly not jimmy's favorite person
but he doesn't think he deserves
something like this after chuck's death
howard blamed himself and it almost
broke him during season 5 we saw that he
turned things around he bounced back he
even tried to reach out and hire jimmy
at hhm this didn't have the desired
effect it actually set jimmy off to
where he was throwing bowling balls at
his car and paying hookers to show up at
fork to embarrass him he overlooked this
at first thinking that jimmy was just
going through something until it all
came to a head when he blew up on him at
the courthouse and then a little bit
later he thought he needed to warn kim
about it when she told him she quit her
job he was coming from a place of saying
that jimmy needed help which to his
credit is true but he came at kim in the
worst way and totally turned her against
him in the process he told her what was
going on in a way that assumed that she
couldn't see that jimmy was having
problems and since in his mind no one
would make the decision to leave her job
he insisted that jimmy must have
influenced her decision in some way she
ended up unloading on him saying do you
have any idea how insulting that is i
make my own decisions for my own reasons
he throws more fuel on the fire saying
you know who really knew jimmy chuck and
she decides that it wouldn't be a big
deal to go after him picking up where
jimmy had already started she assures
her husband that she's prepared to go
through with it and while he doesn't
look nearly as certain you can imagine
that he'll get on board with whatever it
is she wants to do when this series
started it almost functioned as two
shows in one you have what was going on
with jimmy and then you had mike's story
that went off in its own direction as we
near the end things have been drawn
together with the introduction of lalo
mike's story is somewhat overshadowed by
that and what's happening with nacho we
know how things end for mike and at this
point we can see how he got on the
slippery slope of being one of gus's
most trusted guys he took the job
helping with the super lab thinking that
there was a low chance of any violence
being involved and ended up having to
kill someone he had become friends with
in verner that put him on a
self-destructive path in the beginning
of season 5 until gus intervened and
sent him off to mexico there he
explained to him that he needed a
soldier and i'm not sure if he made
enough of a case to have mike set aside
his personal code the thing that had
kept him from going all in on working
with him in the first place but it
certainly opened up the path in season 5
it felt like mike made a decision to
play the hand he was dealt in other
words do what he's good at in service of
providing for kaylee after he's gone
which is pretty rough when you think
about how it all plays out now that gus
has failed to take out lalo it seems
like their showdown will take over most
of the action on that side of the story
and i think i should leave things there
i'm super excited to find out what
happens with gene why kim doesn't appear
to be around anymore during the breaking
bad timeline how this whole thing plays
out with howard whether or not nacho and
his dad make it out and then what
happens to lalo so let me know in the
comments what you're most interested in
what you're thinking about let me know
if you have any questions about what
happened in the series so far tell me
how you think it might end and what you
most want to see happen in this final
season we're coming to the end of the
breaking bad universe and i can't wait
to see how it all ends please like this
video if you enjoyed it please subscribe
to my channel if you haven't already
i'll be doing episode recaps and weekly
bonus videos all throughout this season
so make sure you come back and thanks
for watching i'll talk to you soon